Kim Kardashian and Kanye West enjoy a  date night out I love that a couple who  is expecting their third child a baby  girl  any day now via surrogate stepped out on  Friday night for a casual dinner at  Craigs restaurant in Los Angeles  Kim smiled and waved at fans as she  exited the Hollywood hotspot rocking a  black sweatshirt matching jeans and  thigh high boots her hair down and wavy  Kanye was also dressed down in a black  tee and matching pants pairing his look  with an oversized denim jacket and Yeezy  boots I think they're really excited et  has learned Kim and Kanye have not  chosen a name for their second daughter  yet but a source confirms to each Eve  Kim and Kanye are quote fully prepared  and can't wait to bring their baby home  name bless that I'm able to do this  you